do you ever crave sweets like fruit  mango pineapples and berries no no I  don't really get Cravings anymore I have  managed to reintroduce wild fish I don't  eat wild fish very often because I seem  to just be hungry after I eat it but  it's nice to be able to go out to a  restaurant and Order Sashimi I can eat a  little bit of honey so that's exciting  have I managed to introduce anything  else like fruit absolutely not I still  get autoimmune symptoms if I introduce  fruit I get autoimmune symptoms if I eat  chicken pork is even worse I cannot  tolerate pork at all I have a worse  reaction to Pork than I do to some fruit  like I'd rather be eating apples than  eating pork